All right, let's talk about it.
We're going to dive into one of
those financial arguments that
you see everywhere.
The idea that your small daily
habits are the reason you're not
getting ahead.
But what if that's not the real
story?
What if the actual problem is
way bigger and it's hiding in
plain sight?
You've seen this, right?
Of course you have.
It's a meme.
It's a clap back.
It's basically the collective
eye roll from an entire
generation tired of hearing that
they should just, you know, skip
the small joys in life.
And honestly, it feels totally
fair.
I mean, seriously, can a $6
coffee really be what's standing
between you and a mortgage?
And here's the thing.
You're not wrong that daily
coffee probably isn't the big
bad villain in your financial
story.
But the argument we're digging
into today suggests that we're
all looking in the wrong
direction.
We're missing the real culprit,
this huge invisible force that's
draining our bank accounts month
after month.
And that culprit?
Well, it has a name and it's
borrowed from the high stakes
world of tech startups.
It's called your burn rate.
So what on earth is it?
Well, in Silicon Valley, the
burn rate is just how much cash
a new company blows through
every month just to stay in
business.
We're talking salaries, office
space, the whole shebang.
Now think about that in terms of
your own life.
Your personal burn rate is your
basic cost of living.
And the whole idea here is that
for a lot of us, that baseline
has gotten, well, kind of out of
control.
I mean, just think about how
much our definition of a normal
life has changed.
It's pretty wild when you see it
laid out like this.
What used to be a pretty simple,
low cost way of life has been
replaced by a baseline that's
just packed with expensive
services and gadgets that we now
see as totally standard.
OK, so let's get into the weeds
here.
Let's actually look at the
numbers behind this new normal.
What does it really cost to live
a life that, let's be honest,
most of us wouldn't even think
of as fancy?
Let's start with something easy,
entertainment.
It used to be free, right?
You had ATV, you had an antenna,
and that was that.
Now.
Now the typical household has
this whole collection of
subscriptions.
You know the drill and each one
by itself seems small, but man
do they add up.
Because when you actually tally
them all up, you could easily be
looking at 150, maybe even 200
bucks a month just on media.
That's money that just vanishes
from your account on autopilot.
It's pure uncut monthly burn and
it doesn't stop there.
Next up, food.
We all love convenience, but wow
does it come with a price tag.
A single meal delivered to your
door.
I mean, after the fees, the
delivery charge, a tip, it can
easily hit 3540 bucks no
problem.
Now let's say you do that just
three times a week.
Suddenly you're staring at $500
a month.
That's $6000 a year just for the
luxury of not having to cook.
And this line of thinking
extends to pretty much
everything, especially things
like our cars and just our
general lifestyle expectations.
When leasing a fancy car becomes
the new normal, instead of just
buying a basic, reliable used
one, you end up with what the
author calls a Gordon Gekko
lifestyle masquerading as middle
class Ouch.
So we've seen all the individual
pieces of the puzzle.
Now it's time for the main
event.
Let's put it all together.
Let's actually do the math and
see what the total burn rate for
a normal modern life really adds
up to.
So just take a second and think
about it.
Based on what we've seen so far,
what do you think that number
is?
We're not talking about a life
of luxury here, just the
baseline modern lifestyle.
And get this, this is before you
even pay to keep a roof over
your head.
OK, here it is.
Look at this.
When you add up the
subscriptions, the phone, the
food, the car payment, the
insurance, some basic online
shopping, and just a little bit
for fun, you're already over
$2500.
That is the hole you have to dig
yourself out of every single
month.
But wait, we're not done.
You still have to live
somewhere, right?
So let's add a pretty average
rent to that, say $2000 a month.
All of a sudden, your annual
burn rate is over $54,000.
That's the cost just to exist in
this new normal before you've
saved or invested a single
penny.
So that's a pretty heavy number.
What's the take away here?
Well, it's not about making you
feel guilty.
It's about understanding a cold,
hard choice that you're making
every day, whether you realize
it or not.
The point of all this isn't to
judge anyone for wanting a nice
car or ordering takeout.
Not at all.
The argument is simply that you
can't have it all.
There is a direct mathematical
consequence for every single
lifestyle choice we make, and
this right here is the final
trade off.
It's the whole argument in a
nutshell.
On one side you've got the high
burn rate lifestyle full of all
the modern conveniences, and on
the other side you have the
things that lifestyle might be
costing you.
Investing a safety net, Saving
for big goals, Achieving real
financial freedom.
The hard truth is, for most
people, you can probably have
one or the other, but it's
incredibly difficult to have
both.
So in the end, it's not about
the latte.
It's about this whole ecosystem
of expenses that we've just
accepted as normal.
And it leaves us with a really
powerful and, yeah, maybe a
little uncomfortable question.
Is our modern definition of a
normal life the very thing
that's preventing us from
building a secure one?
It's definitely something to
think about.